it has by any estimating been an
extraordinary last 24 hours in Russia
watch with baited breath around the
world
it seemed at one point that the Putin
regime stood on the brink with a column
of military vehicles heading to Moscow
the leader of the rebels you're gaining
progression of the mercenary group
Wagner has now done a deal to leave for
Belarus
the Rebellion began early yesterday
morning in rostavon Don when forces of
the Wagner group occupied the
headquarters for Russia's military
operations in Ukraine
they then seized control of military
facilities in varnish about 500
kilometers south of Moscow
a Mercury Mercury Convoy then Advanced
north of orange along the M4 Motorway
towards Moscow
Russian forces then erected defensive
positions and blockaded main roads and
bridges along the Route before the order
was given for The Mercenaries to stand
down
well let's get the very latest now from
our Moscow correspondent dynamagne who
is live in the Russian Capital uh good
morning Diana
um what is the mood in Moscow and what
is the military situation as you
understand it
well I mean it's a sunny morning in
Moscow and I think people yesterday were
watching events with a degree of
Confusion And I think in Moscow
especially now they have a a day off
tomorrow so they're probably just
enjoying
um this peaceful resolution and uh I
think though there will be a lot of
people who are questioning what an earth
actually happened
um and given the shadow it sort of casts
over Putin's authority over his
credibility you know bear in mind the
fact that early yesterday morning he
went on television and made a big speech
talking about how this was treasonous a
stab in a part of the Russian people
essentially and only a few hours
backtracked later backtracked and let
pregojin slink off to Belarus where he
is either on route or already in situ it
doesn't look very good for Vladimir
Putin I think there are a lot of
questions being asked as to why on Earth
a uh pregosian who is entirely a man of
the uh kremlin's own making all of his
projects over the last 10 years have
been for serving the kremlin's purposes
why Putin has constructed a system of
the power vertical where he can't get
shoigur garasimov and pregosian sitting
around a table with the
commander-in-chief and hash out the
problems all in one room together why it
has to come to this kind of a a Breaking
Point is entirely Putin's fault because
he just likes to keep these different
factions sort of at arm's length
precaution doesn't really have a direct
line to Vladimir Putin that's why he
likes to shout and rave on social media
all the time so you know this was a very
strange situation but frankly given the
amount of noise that pregozian has been
making over the past three or four
months
um you you know one would have been
foolish to think that it couldn't have
got this far but I think the fact that
there are so many question marks over
how quickly it's resolved does beg a lot
of questions you know now if precaution
is given power and authority to do what
he wants in Belarus that is actually
going to be extremely uncomfortable for
the West for Ukraine for the belarussian
people you know lukashenko is rumored to
be fairly ill he's been in Moscow quite
a lot recently I'm sure that the Kremlin
is looking around for a substitute for
him or for someone who can exert power
in Belarus and
um if pregozian is still somebody who
does heed the words of Vladimir Putin
then um
he would be placed there we understand
from pregozian that he has been offered
governorships here in Russia before and
has refused them this would be quite a
good substitute now if that was part of
the plan then why did Putin come out and
make this speech and end up looking so
bad yesterday you know I don't have the
answers to this kind of thing but the
outcome of pregojin ends up being a
powerful man for Russia in Belarus
against Ukraine against the West well
that suits Putin's purposes
um you know but but we don't know
essentially what happened we don't know
the state of the military perhaps
brigosian just recognized after he made
his announcement and after that column
came up to uh towards Moscow that he
simply didn't have the kind of backing
within the military or within the
security services that he might have
hoped for and that people weren't
turning to him so that's I mean it's
really difficult to know but I think so
yeah sorry Diana that's absolutely
fascinating so is it your estimation
that pagosian actually rather than sort
of riding off into the sunset is
actually going to be a factor or could
actually now be a factor uh in the uh
Ukraine war
um well I mean he has been a
considerable factor in the Ukraine war
hasn't he because of his Wagner
mercenaries
um if he's positioned in Belarus if
Wagner takes more of a role in Belarus
if he's given power in Belarus which is
essentially up to Vladimir Putin rather
than Alexander lukashenko uh then
Belarus comes even more under the remit
of Putin
um but it just depends if he's allowed
to take on that kind of power in in
Belarus or not and then if you have a
Wagner mercenary sitting in in Belarus
there are already lots of Russian
military bases there that in effect
gives more of a pincer movement around
Ukraine so I'm speculating here but
we'll have to see how much Authority
he's allowed to wield or if he's just
sort of essentially relegated there and
sits in Exile as as is the way it's
being cast in some circles now
um but if he is still Putin's man he
could be useful for him there
Diana thank you we'll keep uh keep
looking out for your uh fascinating
analysis on this as the days go by thank
you very much